[Music]
welcome back to another amazing episode
of the careful boys and today we have an
amazing person who just joined us again
we've got julia gulia in the building
everybody
[Applause]
i haven't seen you in so freaking long
like what the hell it's like been
forever [ __ ] julia
oh my god
[Laughter]
steve
[Music]
oh my god
i'm dripping i'm dripping
literally you are
dripping in swag bro isn't it hot like
it's very hot in this yeah is this worth
it is this the results of vegas money
this is what vegas did to me there's
something new about you i don't know
what it is that's a he's a poker wife
yeah on poker wife i haven't even been
there for 10 months and this is what
happens to you you start thinking this
stuff looks cool slowly slowly slowly
start adding the card add in the card
start checking out
wait hold on poker wife
you don't know about nikki's poker thing
she's i've been i've been off the
internet now a professional poker player
that is not a joke we live in that
reality our time yeah yeah she won like
a hundred grand like at a tournament
into the multiverse
so which is absurd she's a big deal 90
grand of it went to his outfit yeah
easily this is expensive
just my watch you
know
wow
does she so she i mean assuming that she
won money right that she was in a
competition
she was uh in the world series of poker
yeah she finally tabled big deal
out of like 5700 people she killed off
like 5700 people she's final four she's
literally his sugar mom though yeah
that's amazing she lost a million
dollars at the same time which is pretty
sick so did you know about that it all
worked out it worked out at exactly the
right time that's true because we never
see you on instagram
nah dude but you see my you see my uh my
crypto holdings on instagram that's
about it
so kurt is not doing so well well it
depends on your definition of so well
look at them if you if you come on like
is that nikki money or is that your
money have you been thrown into a
volcano before
and then afterward you say that's good
it's going pretty well so well
the point is we survived the volcano we
did and you know what like metal we are
being melted down impurities being
removed it is time to cool down and
harden and harden and harden and as we
become valuable again i'm waiting for
the moment he takes off his shades and
we see that this is like domestic abuse
at home
two black guys
nikki's been kicking my [ __ ] ass
what's under your jumpsuit
this is
just a t-shirt
that's why you can't take it off
what do you mean so we can go walking
we thought you were gonna have an encore
under there like there'd be just another
outfit yeah
what matches with with under that like a
like a wife meter like a gold wipe yeah
like a gold one
i'm waiting for just a second jumpsuit
under it
and then more chains we're just getting
going dude this is the this is this is
act one is that where did where did you
get that
i got this on amazon everything on
amazon [ __ ] yeah of course what did you
type in
i typed in
but i don't want to give them money so
like what's like off kenji's like the
off kid just jumping you got a matching
kinja's [ __ ]
necklace right there oh that's a tiger
dude i bought it hitting one of these
dude so i went out with
one of these what is that just logo is
that what you can't do typing in kid
just gets you this
dude
so so my neighbor is actually like super
[ __ ] successful poker players right
and so we we were going out with them
a couple nights ago and i i had just
gotten this in the mail and i was like
dude i'm gonna [ __ ] break it in
i can't not wear it you gotta break it
in it looks warm yeah so i so i take it
uh i put it on and [ __ ] and then they
come pick us up and then i just come out
of my house and i start locking my door
and like i see them in the cars being
like
do they know this side of you
i mean yeah but not but i hadn't i'd
only worn like colts jerseys and [ __ ]
out you know what i mean like you guys
know how would i wear it i've never not
seen you in a jersey yeah i wear jerseys
and [ __ ] i must i'm a big sports guy
you know
finding the sports book but no but so so
yeah then they're they're just like holy
[ __ ] and like my buddy mormon he is like
really well known in the poker community
so the whole night
like i have to be i'm like around him
wearing this [ __ ] and people think
you're legit like people think
[Music]
well that's what happens when you're
with your friends right everyone's like
oh my god they're hanging out with this
[ __ ] guy yeah
who's that guy
were you acting any different like were
you in another character were you just
before i was talking with the friends i
was completely normal but then like if
anybody's coming up you know i try to be
a little loud about something like yeah
you know yeah i was getting out of this
stock but i was like yeah i gotta get
out of this one
[Laughter]
you're the wall street guy yeah the
pretend rich man that's not gold
whatever it was a blast
on gold i have a bunch on me you like
call someone for that dude i think maybe
the most disappointing thing that
happened to me though during this uh
outfit was i was out and i saw some jk
fan
and he comes up to me and he doesn't
even mention the outfit like it's
completely normal
and he expected me to be wearing
something
i mean you look pretty fresh coming out
from the car thank you but that was the
worst part did you wear your shades on
the whole night yeah i did that's
[ __ ] fire yeah but i didn't have
these gold ones yet because it didn't
come yet in the mail so i had i had my
ray-ban ballaramas but you know why it's
because in vegas i think people expect
that like they expect dad a girl half
naked a [ __ ] guy throwing up in the
middle of the casino yeah you look like
you're on the uh uh the right side of
the vegas trip you know the one with the
flamingo and stuff not the left side
yeah
in between the wind and the [ __ ]
caesar's palace but dude i look like
half the guys on the ward poker tour and
[ __ ] yeah they're doing this [ __ ] you're
a poker shark
[Laughter]
did nikki dress up with you when you
wore that out i mean she looked hot as
[ __ ] but but she was definitely not
going for funny
she was going for [ __ ] or like i'm
wearing my well
what did she say she's 1980s jersey wife
yeah
did she match you as a jersey as a
jersey wife kind of stuff or i wish
that's my dream wife but that would be
perfect
that's my dream she knows this she knows
it's like my dream is like the trashy i
love [ __ ]
everything trash she wanted america
she's got the black stripes right here
and [ __ ] like that hey why not
you wanted to marry snooki
yeah i love all that [ __ ] yeah i love
that [ __ ] that'd be fire
yeah i feel like your danger boy
character would
be really good in that suit thank you
very much you look really like it would
just match i appreciate that yeah you
look like you're a co-owner of like a
football club
i i do other soccer club for sure he
looks like he sports bets but always
fails yeah
if you were like dripped out on all this
fake chain and stuff and then you were
getting robbed what would you say
i would say not the necklace man
this is literally nineteen dollars
i'm like no hey not the necklace
it's kind of heavy too for 90 bucks
that's gonna be our next costume but how
are you julia i'm good i'm good
i've uh i've just been working i feel
like it's just been kind of like a
boring life but also not so boring why
are you so bad at quitting jk i don't
know um bart just reached out to me and
he was asking me if i could come in i
rejected him a few times just because i
was just to stick it to your old bosses
[ __ ] you
also it's a thursday i am surprised yeah
you got the day off oh yeah so um the
pto what's up no no uh i actually got
the whole month off let's go maternity
leave oh my god
dude imagine me being a mom and i can't
even i think you make a good mom
dude that's a lot of responsibility
there's like a whole life in you so
we're just gonna gloss over who the [ __ ]
gets a month off yeah yeah that's true
um my my producer is really nice about
it he actually brought me on to another
project early and he was like he was
harassing you sexually that gave me no
no
he's leveraging something here that
would never happen at jk by the way he's
cool he's cool i really like him a lot
okay okay okay but um yeah he was just
saying that i have some time before like
things get really busy so um if i wanted
to take a break i should take it now
you would like to take an unpaid break
and then he's like julia doesn't know we
fired her
oh no no no no contracting everything
we're sorry sweetie
contracts and everything we're signed
steve hiring all right so what what is
the job again what do you do again um i
do i'm a production coordinator
animation she got some stuff on netflix
yeah
so you said things are going to start
getting really busy what's uh uh that
will be like in november what's the
really busy
they're really busy yeah like can we
know what project going on oh you're
part of an animation house right yeah
yeah so then i'm assuming you guys have
something that you're introducing it's
going into production there's a lot
going in production but for me i don't
get busy until november but then in my
personal life
i feel like yeah in my personal life
uh which you don't share online no not
as much but i'm thinking about starting
again because i feel like it's been what
like two years off of the internet
during lockdown you just kind of went
quiet yeah everything went quiet so what
are you gonna do for this month off do
you have any plans do you have any like
cool things here i'm gonna try to film a
tick tock
what i don't know how old it's gonna go
absolutely do a tick tock we'll do it
don't be nervous about filming a tick
tock have you watched tick tock i
i'm still shy about this you know the
other day
the volume goes up
you're doing you're fighting your
subconscious i see it
so like i had an artist actually um that
was like leaving one of the projects i
was working on
and the entire time i didn't know that
she was a fan and so when she was
leaving she was like hell by the way i
hope this isn't awkward and i was like
what and she was like oh i really like i
watched like jk when i was like growing
up and stuff and like thank you for
repping all the asian girls like on
youtube media and i was like oh my god
stop i mean i feel so shy like please
stop i can't i can't and it was like the
sweetest message ever really well
[Laughter]
then i like did something to her [ __ ]
cervix i don't know what happened i'm
supposed to grab boba sometime
that's the most asian [ __ ] i've ever
heard oh
oh
yeah cute that's amazing yeah but like
you know honestly when she said that
though i totally forgot i lived a life
on youtube
wow you forgot
youtube is a very dinosaur age now it's
all about
so what's your angle like where how are
you trying to jump in the tick tock game
i have no idea
like literally yeah what kind of tick
tock videos do you like watch the
blackout challenge blackout challenge
that's the first game
wait what so what do you what do you
don't even google
like fishing videos like
what kind of videos you want there's
like there's makeup videos i think i see
like the typical trends like things that
are just trending so like those like
dance stuff and then i think there's
ones where it's like they have
narratives where they play the song and
then they talk about a disaster that
happened to him
um that's interesting i played this song
on your last video
yeah your last disaster yeah your last
one your last dessert i like
farmers showing us their harvest yeah
i've seen those really good yeah there's
like natives to talk about so she gets
into that she's like all right
that one's on my obviously jungle starts
building water slides really really fast
that was my thing i've always wanted it
yeah yeah so i don't i don't know what
content i'll make you know you're gonna
post one i'm just gonna post it just do
it please do it right
now do it
what do you like to do on your own time
as a hobby number one favorite thing i
like to see pulling it out right that's
the real question i need to ask that's a
great don't think i've been getting into
hiking
then hike hike
oh another one is um laying in bed
does that count yep girls can get away
with it yeah okay depends honestly yeah
wearing yeah girls can get away with
anything there's this one i know
there's this tick tock trend that i saw
go around where um they're like hey they
say don't hang your feet on the side of
the bed cause monsters will eat it and
then they put their butt on the side
because they want their butt to be eaten
that's a good first one for you exactly
that's what you're all about i know
right
that's a good debut just like here's a
cheek boom yeah that's joe's algorithm
he's just like hashtag eat ass
she's every challenge while joe watch us
we do know that that's a fact though i
don't even watch tick tock so ha got you
there i saw it on reels
but you're on tick tock though josie
only dude watching wheels
just are you on same soccer i have but i
don't really watch it like i think like
i'm just scrolling through instagram and
then some people repost their ticket
we're one of those corporate businesses
that we're like we need a tick tock in
2022
we hired this this 45 year old man to
take care of it
he has a marketing degree he knows
exactly what's going on yeah is there a
jk thing
no no
no there's no jk tick tock the visual
ones i've seen joe's that i never post
on
i barely post someone that's what we're
gonna do that's gonna pop off okay what
about those knockouts when somebody gets
knocked out on like a reel or a tick
tock i feel like that's something you
watch like four times in a row like a
fight oh yeah like a fight you gotta
find some people to knock it out
i got you though what tick-tock allows
those to stay on but you know like
like there's like fight videos and stuff
like that right you can't tell them
they're about to get knocked out because
it always looks like they're acting yeah
yeah yeah yeah
that they always they flinch have that
disclaimer like no one was hurt oh i'll
take it away someone was clearly hurt
you know they um
they took down well they froze my video
because um i was drifting in my friend's
diesel truck in the snow and they said
that's unsafe and harmful to children
and then i contested it and then they
let me have it again but after that i
was like [ __ ] tick tock dude me and joe
did an instagram story one time where he
was on a skateboard and i threw a shoe
at the skateboard wheels while he's on
it
that's definitely unsafe for kids but
that was a tight video
did you trip did you fall yeah [ __ ] it
he fell on his [ __ ] head but
instagram allowed us to keep it up yeah
yeah see that's why i like instagram
better what about that instagram is just
like tick tock now did you see that that
uh kim kardashian everybody petitioned
they're like bring it back you're about
pictures tick tocks about videos stop
trying to be tick-tock and they try to
be all like have the black screen and
everything like tickets aren't they
aren't they putting it back yeah i think
so but that's totally true though right
it's like what be the exact same thing
stop being a copycat well
zuckerberg this is yuck
do you feel inspired with all these tick
tock ideas yeah we gave you so much a
wealth of information this is free by
the way yeah yeah you should be paying
us actually yeah there's food genre
there is a hiking genre have you seen
that one that's been going around where
it's like when i go hike i get out of my
car to go on top and then i turn around
go back to my car that one have you seen
that one uh
i think i've seen variations of it you
oh yeah
yeah she looks like she could just sit
there and just eat a giant sea cucumber
that looks like a penis and go wow right
you know what i'm talking about i don't
like i don't like sea cream but you like
noodles i love you you're a noodle girl
also don't you don't you play games
no you don't play video video
you should parts she fits the role but
she does it i guess do i do i fit the
role of the gamer you call you don't
look like a guy i thought you were
you're probably cosplaying on the
weekends or show up as like a doll or a
furry that is actually something i i'm
kind of interested in cosplay you should
do that you should cosplay you would
love that right this is what you're
gonna do you're gonna do hiking and then
after you do your hiking videos you go
get some mukbangs and then you dress up
in uh you cosplay for both and then now
you're [ __ ] owning the niche like
you're you're cosplaying on the hiking
multi-faceted what am i doing with my
life i should just come back to youtube
dude if i'm telling you we'll be
consultants for you just taking this
right here yeah if you told me like if i
just met you and you're like i'm on
twitch i would totally believe you i
would 100 believe yeah but if you said
hiking i don't know if
like i said i'm just starting to get
into it guys yeah
you don't have any timberlands do you
have all trails
do you have an account on all trails
i'll show you what's the real deal okay
are you paying premium are you going pro
route do you have one of these no
sounds like you're not much bikers
dude you got everyone gotta have a metal
one i have a water backpack
julia i know what you should do you know
those you guys seen those videos where
the girls put the camera like on their
butt and they walk through new york and
they just get cat called do that but
with hiking yeah yeah and see if people
look at your butt you know what i mean
lumberjack is like hey baby
that's how they get you dude
you think she hits us up and she's like
i have so much [ __ ] footage but
there's like nobody
i've hiked 48 miles in the last four
days i have gigabytes and gigabytes and
terabytes there's nobody in the [ __ ]
someone whistled it was just a sparrow
it was such a good idea it was so
different and unique yeah i miss you
guys
i miss being here just honestly like for
the past two years of working in like
production for animation like the first
year it seemed really hectic because i
was just like learning a bunch of things
but then in my second year i was like
wow i kind of have this time after 7 00
p.m like what what do i do with myself
and over here we overworked you and you
don't have to over here over here was
just crazy it was just like different
things every day so like i just felt
like i had all the hobbies around and
then now when i was just working like
okay cool and then my job was like
now what
yeah
get into hobbies huh did you get into
hockey i mean i'm starting to because
now i'm just like yeah
wow i feel like i have a balance now
that's true like we need a little bit of
crazy back i do
because it's like you might be location
scouting one day at the forest and then
the next day you're cleaning up my vomit
that i [ __ ] puked at jk party yeah
and then the next day we've changed
though he doesn't do the floors thing
anymore no yeah
there's still a lot of i'm much more
chilled out now but does joe still walk
around the office barefoot and his oh
[ __ ]
no no it's just that his foot gets black
at the end of the day it gets black i'm
wearing this is how black my foot got
that's not a shoe that's okay that's the
feature of jk
that's a big highlight that's a really
funny symptom
bart still walks around his underwear
it's completely normal we fired the hr
guy his butt is bigger
yeah he really achieved his gorilla form
yeah everybody everybody here matured
and really you know started respecting
women a lot more oh yeah i'm drinking
i'm dripping over here too yeah dude i'm
[ __ ] dripping from head to toe
steve's glow up it has been crazy yeah
it's been wild to see nick's finally
opening up don't talk to me dude end the
video
[Laughter]
oh yeah by the way nick has the
authority to end any video
he just says in the video he doesn't end
the video that's it you're going to be
in otr and this is it's two minutes in
nick says in the video it's over you
guys can't talk to me i could only ask
questions that's it that's my role here
we know we just can't talk to you at all
i know i got the meaning thank you guys
i gotta do it thank you respecting my
boundaries i do and that's why we're
sitting together
you